all right this is this is sad news our
good friend
who has filled in for me before
a Jesse dollamore announced yesterday
that he sadly has cancer
and he has a whole video message about
it to his audience and he explains that
he went in for and this is there's a
Twitter thread that you can look at
um he went in for a colonoscopy late
last week
and yesterday he was told that he has
colon cancer
and there's a mass and it is
um adenocarcinoma
does not yet know the stage or the
prognosis but believes that it's not
stage four meaning it hasn't spread to
other organs
Jesse's going to need surgery
he is going to then learn is it stage
one or two in which case that's
hopefully the end of the journey or as
he writes if it's three then he would
start chemo
there's a lot of uncertainty
and
um we are all pulling for Jesse as uh as
I tweeted to him yesterday I was just on
a call with Jesse because we were
working on some stuff and Jesse is super
graciously filled in for me in the past
uh last summer and he's just a really
nice guy the the thing about Jesse is
that
um the nice guy that you see in his
Clips is really Jesse and
um it's horrible news and I know that
lots of our other friends in the uh
Progressive media Community are rallying
around Jesse there's no ask here right
now I'm just telling you all about
something in the community that's going
on that's that's horrible so
um feel free to send Jesse a tweet we're
of course wishing him the best or you
know you can leave positive vibes over
on the video clip that he did about out
this or really just whatever but we send
Jesse our best really sad news and we
hope to have good news from Jesse about
treatment and prognosis sooner than
later all right Jesse everybody here is
pulling for you